[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual and amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and hosts begin
intro he's my co-host today he talks
about jobs and careers and money and
well in a way that you love it and so if
you got questions about all that you
jump in we'll talk about it and anything
else you want to do we talk about you
right in front of you and we make a
living doing it phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jump in Marvin is going to start us off
this hour in New York Albany to be
precise hey Marvin welcome to the Ramsay
show
um hi Dave and Ken
um privilege to be able to speaking with
you
um
um thank you very much
for all that you do well thank you how
can we help
um so so a real brief
um I'm 40.
um
um my wife is 34. Right Said we've been
married for 12 years and started a
Turfgrass Consulting business uh with
the money that we received from our
wedding
right so we do work for
local mom and pop golf courses and
conduct field trials Forge plant
protectant manufacturers
I was able to go full time with the
business in 2018
and she was able to go full time in
2020.
um in January thanks to you guys we were
able to become debt free by paying off
our house
um one of our clients will be selling
their Golf Course soon uh so my question
for you is uh should we buy it for 1.2
million dollars
well the first question is can Dave and
I play for free
it could affect our answer
no pressure Mark I'm kidding lifetime
membership yeah the uh it's gonna cost
you Marvin it's going to cost you about
this advice is going to be free today
Dave yeah yeah so I okay 1.2 million
and so this thing is uh has a net profit
after all salaries are paid
including whatever the owner is paying
himself to manage the course because
it's a mom and pop
um this thing is making uh 300 000 a
year
that no it's doing uh doing about the
one 150 to to a 200 net
okay
so why in the world would you pay 1.2
for that
that's overpriced
yeah I I mean
um you know I I know what know what no
the golf course business uh fairly well
the uh infrastructure in the in the golf
course of business
um the
the the uh the war thought comes from
the assets right so meaning or it's a
golf carts rides maintenance equipment
uh things like that yeah now the worst
doesn't come from that no those things
only have a value to the extent they
create a profit
okay if all of those things created zero
profit you would have what's known as a
hobby
okay not a business and so the golf
carts the infrastructure the quality of
the turf the everything there the name
the reputation in the community uh the
area of town it's in all of that goes to
create one thing profit and the way you
calculate profit is net profit uh a
small business is worth a maximum of
five times net profit
five times that property that's a 20
press a 20 rate of return
and you know small business purchase is
a very high risk purchase and so you
would want at least a 20 rate of return
and that's after that's if you're an
absentee owner and so let's say I bought
it
for in Tennessee okay and I I had to
hire a manager and I had to hire every
single staff member that was needed not
you get to work over there for free or
the a former owner gets to work over
there for free and thereby increase the
profits you follow me
real profits for an absentee investor
this is how you calculate the value of a
small business transfer and it's called
a cap rate process capitalization rate
um
the only other way you could calculate
the value is the what's called Book
value which would be considerably less
and that is if you took all if you
bought it and you sold off all the
assets you sold off the golf carts you
sold off the real estate you sold off
the you collected the receivables you
paid the payables and that's Book value
that should be less than
four times five times net profit it
should be uh but that's that's if you
were going to disband the whole
operation and it's worth more shut down
than it is operationally then
I doubt that's the case here because I
got to tell you man I'm I don't know a
ton about the golf business but there's
kind of a joke in the investment world
that the guy that makes the money on a
golf course is the second owner the guy
that makes the money on ski slope is the
second owner because the first one
usually goes bankrupt
there's not much there's not much margin
or spread in that world very low margins
and so yeah just be careful to not
overpay for it if you're going to pay
cash for it Marvin and you want to buy
it it sounds like you know the golf
business at least the side of it that
you've been in but um I'm telling you
the finances on this deal they don't
sound that great
um and if the guy goes well the real
estate's worth a lot then he ought to
just sell the real estate
if the real estate's worth more than a
million too then you ought to just sell
the real estate put condos on it or
whatever uh because I mean from a from a
business transaction standpoint not a
romantic view of grass and trees and
ponds The Real Estate is unquestionably
the most valuable part of this purchase
a mom and pop Golf Course is a
mom-and-pop golf course for a reason not
knocking them I've played some awesome
little munis in my life and they're
great but this is a low margin business
and you probably don't have the
clientele
you look at how old your your average
member or your average golfer is I'd be
running all those things Beyond
everything that Dave mentioned and
unless this is a burning conviction and
you got the cash for it and you can
handle it I'd run away from it unless
it's a real estate purchase only I mean
it's just such a low margin business and
you're competing against in that area
you're competing against higher end
clubs that are charging much much more
and you're just limited in your growth
with a small golf course you're limited
your Revenue growth is limited Gotta
Love the Way Ken throws around the
inside or lingo wow what did I say at a
lot of really good munis in my time I'm
sorry a municipal course I should you're
right that was inside this side golf
lingo it just means a local public
course not a private course it's public
anybody can play I've played a lot of
really nice communities in my lifetime
that was pretty good Ken I like the way
you did that you slipped that right in
there it's just added to your level of
expertise it was an accident
grew at one no that's all I could afford
to play my dad that's all we could play
were Muniz when I was growing up on a
pastor's income
when I think communities I think a
municipal bonds Muni bonds oh in the
golf world that just means
I figuring it out I figured it out no
it's not necessarily a go tractor or
something there are there's a very nice
ones yes I do know what go track means
it means horrible golf course yeah I do
tell you a great one in the Virginia
Beach area Stumpy Lake oh there's a
great Municipal Golf Course great name
Stumpy Lake yeah a bunch of tree stumps
all over the lake well-known Muni as of
today useless information
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three
months free to get started that's three
months free to prioritize your mental
health and be intentional about finding
peace through calming music prayers
meditation and more and hallow isn't
just Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this is a
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Paulo is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hollow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personalities my
co-host today thanks for being with us
America we appreciate you hanging out
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from
neighborly your hub for Home Services
most American homes have dozens of
appliances and chances are at any given
time there's something wrong with at
least one of them Mr Appliance a
neighborly brand offers expert appliance
service on your schedule visit
neighborly.com today to find Home
Service Experts including Mr Appliance
in your area today's question comes from
Neil in Wisconsin I'm wanting to get my
degree in the financial industry what is
the average starting salary for someone
who is straight out of college and what
would their position be how much room
for promotion and growth is in this
industry and how do I set myself up for
Success uh Neil I don't know off the top
of my head what an average starting
salary is because this is kind of a big
ambiguous question in the financial
industry covers a lot of different
specifics you can be everything from
bank teller to CEO yeah so that's a
pretty wide range but the second part of
the question we can address
how much room for promotion and growth
is in this industry well again depending
on the Lane that you pick within the
financial industry think of it as a
track and field track there's six eight
Lanes there multiple Lanes of pins you
can do very very well there's no
question you could do high six figures
and you could be a seven figure earner
uh in the world of Finance I mean
there's just no question about that
that's everything from Wall Street to an
investment professional that does very
very well so the sky's the limit is the
answer to this how do you set yourself
up for success that's the uh that's the
answer the answer to that is is doesn't
matter on the industry I think it is
three parts You Gotta Know Your Role on
every level that you're at that's
Clarity do I know what's expected of me
the second thing is accept the role win
the now have an attitude of gratitude
for where you are and bust it there is
no next if you don't win the now then
third maximize the role go above and
beyond don't walk around acting like
you're the CEO but then work like you
are like you own the place that's Know
Your Role except your role maximize your
role that's Clarity attitude and effort
I think if you do that on every level
that you're at you're always going to be
promotable yeah absolutely and you know
bathe
smile show up on time smile
uh don't don't be an entitled twit and
um these things will take you a long way
that's true I mean it's because really I
mean in a world of uh
people who don't do those basic things
you you really do set yourself apart
right yeah it's just a big deal just
show up on time you know and uh wow so
uh
yeah so Neil the the the the problem
that we're having answering the question
is it's like saying I'm going to get a
marketing degree what do marketing
people make
well there's about eight eighty thousand
different things marketing people do
and the same thing's true with financial
a finance degree I have a finance degree
with a specialization in real estate
um and because I wanted to be in the
real estate business that was my goal I
grew up in the real estate business that
was the long-term thing but I've got all
the financial
goober classes under my belt now and so
a thousand years ago I did and uh um so
you know now what are you gonna do with
that there's a lot of different things
you know like Ken said corporate
position as a financial analyst
um and but Finance in general Finance
and Accounting are really good uh
Baseline
uh sets of knowledge to move into
companies and do very well uh for
instance there's two primary sources for
the CEO of major companies in America
today almost all the CEOs and major
companies in America today are either
former
CFOs or Finance people accounting people
uh Bean counters of some kind or another
or they were the director of marketing
and sales
that's the primary two primary pools
that CEOs come out of the people that
bring in the revenue and the people that
manage and operate the business well
from a numbers perspective and have a
higher likelihood of becoming CEOs very
few people come from the graphic arts
department to become the CEO and that's
not the put down the graphic arts
department it's just a statistical fact
and so you know you look at where that's
taking you so uh but yeah it's a great
degree as a baseline of knowledge
because in getting that degree it's a
it's a basic Business Degree you're
going to end up with good statistics
under your belt go to Counting under
your belt you're going to end up with
marketing classes under your belt and
you know those are going to be those
will be knowledge bases that you'll use
wherever you land in business so all of
that sets you up for a positive
situation Carla is in Florida hey Carla
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you for having me so
we appreciate you being here how can we
help
so I have some questions I've been
plowing through
my baby steps and especially paying off
like credit cards good for you and
I I don't have anything saved up in
retirement I'm a nurse I've been a nurse
for 25 years I make 138 000 plus a year
uh my home is paid off my biggest
expense is my car which I owed 23 000 on
and my interest rate is 4.4 percent
so I first I'm going through these baby
steps but I was paying off cards
yesterday so I paid off six cut them up
way to go threw away all the papers so
that I wouldn't be tempted to call them
back for a new car
and now I ran into the next one that I
wanted to pay off and they said if I pay
it off see this one has an annual fee
and they said if I paid it off it was
going to dig my credit
and you know just keep the card and pay
the annual fee but I was like well
how much is that going to ding my credit
and does that matter because that's the
next card to pay off I have five more to
pay off so wait a minute let me get this
straight a credit card company told you
it's not a good idea to get rid of a
credit card
right no they said keep it open you're
kidding it's gonna hurt my credit if I
closed it yeah of course they did yeah
well it is it's gonna it is gonna damage
your credit score so the question is
this where is it we're trying to get to
is is a credit score your goal or is
money your goal
um retirement is my goal yeah having and
by the way I've had people try to boil
their credit score you can't eat it
it's worthless you know what a credit
score is good for there's only one thing
a credit score is good for you know what
it is
get more credit borrowing more money
going into debt which is kind of the
opposite of having money for retirement
it's the opposite of what you're trying
to accomplish right now so if your goal
is to get rid of your debt so that you
have some money
who cares about your credit score
yeah and you know I I you drove right
past that and you didn't even get it
yes how old are you
I am 60. you're killing it with 138 000
girl I'm proud of you very good yeah
let's get these cards chopped up and get
rid of this car payment and start piling
up some money so five or six years from
now you've got 250 300 000 set aside
let's quit screwing around credit card
if I could
if I can pay all my cards off within the
next two months
and then then knock out that 23 000 car
loan
in a year and oh you can do it faster
than that you make 130 you ain't got
anything else to do
this is important well I I do help my
mom and my daughter out
well and to the EXT how much do you give
them
um okay my mother's car insurance
and and my daughter about 500 or man an
85 year old car insurance
yeah
does that seem weird to you
that's scary to me but she's only living
on Social Security yeah I know so
where's the 85 year old driving to
the grocery store yeah I thought so this
is pretty expensive trips
so um you need to think through what
where your money's going and get control
of it and for sure we don't take advice
from credit card companies on anything
all we do to them is say bye-bye
wouldn't want to be you are the
cigarette of the financial World your
credit card goobers we don't want
anything to do with you this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
I'm Dave Ramsey your host open phone's a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ben is in New York hi Ben welcome
to the Ramsay show
how are you doing great man what's up
um I am currently living with my parents
I am 29. I've been saving for several
years now and I'm trying to figure out
if I am ready to buy a house and if I
can afford to you know get my own place
at this point
okay how much do you have saved
uh 100k
okay
uh what keeps you from leaving there and
buying a house
um well I was mostly just trying to
reach a certain I was trying to reach
that goal of 100 100K stage okay you got
100K you got 100K I mean Common Sense
tells me you could go buy a house in
Albany with 100K you're 29 years old how
much do you make
uh about 70 75. cool all right
I I would definitely do it like this
week
you think you think that's a good idea
because I didn't want to rent I didn't
want to be throwing out money you know
dude impulsive is not on your list of
things to do yeah
we don't have to worry about you being
impulsive you're 29 you live at home
you're not impulsive okay all right time
to go yes go get you a house get you a
life
yeah for sure no I like it I love it man
so how much do you make again
70. what do you do 70s
I'm a working accounting
okay you are risk averse aren't you man
you're just hey um it's time man
go out in the sun see the sunshine the
uh the uh you are a numbers dude I love
you I'm a nerd I'm a numbers nerd too
man so I'm right there with you Ben
you've been crunching numbers and
crunching numbers and crunching numbers
and the problem with those numbers nerds
is and you're you're one I'm one so I'm
owning it with you we can get paralysis
of the analysis and you have a bad case
sure get a house get a life go go go do
it I mean go have some fun man go get
you know and and tell your mama you love
her and you'll see her in five months
yeah I mean she's gonna be she's gonna
be glad to get rid of you I promise I
don't think she is actually well I think
that's part of the he's an easy guy to
live with he is he's not but let me tell
you something it's not like he's having
parties in the basement or something
we're seeing more and more of this and
I'm not picking on no Ben but I do want
to say this Ben goes there's two things
that are going on number one he's got
the analysis paralysis situation but he
also along with the fear of change is
how comfortable he is at Mom's house
and that can just keep you when you
because you can justify stain
by using the numbers and I think it got
to be realistic how much of this is I'm
just afraid to kind of go out and start
adulting that wasn't even a term 10
years ago and I hate saying it I'm a
little embarrassed that I even uttered
it yeah but I mean it's time for a lot
a great callback uh but yeah I just
think we got too many young
20-somethings that are just terrified of
change and we gotta call that let me
just tell you when you're out there and
on the wire and there's no net
um it is terrifying and it's also
exhilarating and it it's also what makes
you a man or makes you a woman my son
yeah so yeah
um I hey
um you know yes Ben you should go buy a
house and we're not picking on you but
you did open the can of worms so we'll
deal with it for a second um
here's the thing moms and dads you're
not doing uh your kiddos favors when you
leave them in the nest too long a eagle
that stays in the nest too long becomes
known as a turkey and Ben I didn't just
call you a turkey I'm talking about a
concept here okay so Ben you're you're
free from this you we love you we're
happy for you I'm glad you got 100K you
need to buy a house in the next month
and you need to move immediately for
your sake and it's good it's good you
know we're there but uh so I our oldest
when she came out of school easy kid oh
yeah Denise to this day she's just a
pleasant easy person and
um and she moved back to our she's the
only one of them that moved back to our
house after college and uh she was
waiting on a roommate situation to
develop so she could go get the first
rental property right and
um
so she was living there for about uh two
months and we said okay that's probably
enough
and she's like what I'm like you know
you got it you gotta get this done
because not because we don't like it she
was not in our way she's like Ben she
could have lived there and we wouldn't
have noticed she'd been there until
she's 29 we wouldn't have noticed but uh
we're like no you are missing out on
life
when when you're 22 23 25 years old and
you live in your mama's basement you're
missing out on life and so you need to
go be somebody and um it breaks our
heart because we love you we like having
you around but uh it's not about us it's
about you and your development as a
person you're emotional you're
psychological your Spiritual Development
your financial development you become a
different person when you buy your own
eggs and pay your own light bill and
fold your own clothes or don't but
they're your clothes yeah and that it
just changes there's a little thing
happens there a little different thing
and again Ben for God's sakes we're not
picking on you okay we're not you called
up you're a nice young man we appreciate
you none of this is aimed at you but I'm
just telling you folks moms and dads you
are stunting their growth 100 reminds me
of that movie with Matthew McConaughey
Failure to Launch horrible movie I don't
know I think it's a great Matthew
Matthew has done some really good work
in his life and that is not on the list
this is exciting folks Dave Ramsey with
a strong opinion on a rom-com
I I never thought I'd see the day I mean
if your co-stars Terry Bradshaw I'm just
saying you're right okay the quality of
the script writing was low I'll give you
that but but when Stacy wants to see it
I say oh yeah well yeah there is that
I'm blaming it on her yeah I would
I'm blaming it on you but we're all
right Joe is in Louisville Kentucky hi
Joe what's up
hi thanks for having me guys how are you
better than we deserve how can we help
good um so uh just quick background uh
last year I had uh I left the job that I
was at for about 15 years uh since then
I've been struggling to uh you know find
a job uh to make what I need to make to
pay the bills and I'm primarily using
job boards and they just seem to not be
going anywhere that's horrible yeah
resources out there I guess what were
you making
um I was making about 130 000 a year
doing what it was commissioned so it
kind of went up and down uh sales and uh
management okay and why did you walk out
the door without having anything to go
to
uh well they uh had a new ownership come
through in one of the first changes they
made was pay uh for the regional manager
so I ended up
um was on the pace for about 70k after
they uh took over okay in half and you
said you said stick it okay I got that
yeah all right so have you been working
go ahead
yeah I've been working um I'm currently
making
um right now about 55k a year so do you
know how to sell
yes I I can sell what were you selling
before when you're making 130
uh it's furniture
wholesale are the customers I mean
I'm sorry yeah a customer uh customer
two customers so okay retailer okay wow
I gotta tell you my mom uh sold
Furniture was a manager of a large
furniture chain for 35 years and if you
can make that kind of money in Furniture
those margins aren't that high uh you've
got a lot of options in front of you
right now a lot and you've got to stop
job boarding and you've got to start
start having coffee with people that you
know Civic clubs churches you know
people and look you can sell anything
you're not a guy who's stuck in an
industry in other words you aren't just
effective in the furniture industry you
know a product you know a service not
only can you sell it Joe but you let a
team of people medical device sales you
can make two and a quarter easy
easy
so with I've looked at some medical like
sales jobs I I just feel like
um you know I I don't feel like it's you
know I'm qualified I guess for it you
you just apply anyways yes there aren't
doctors making the sales they're sales
people sales two doctors yeah I got a
friend who's got who's a former college
football player I'm not knocking
football players he's advising surgeons
on Orthopedic devices in the operating
room not because he's a genius because
they trained him on the devices Dave's
right you don't need anything other than
a willingness to learn and basic
intelligence and you have both of those
in droves hey we're going to send you
Ken's book from paycheck to purpose I
want you to go on his website and learn
his uh oh yeah oh no also we're gonna
send you a proximity press that's what
these are the number one because that's
that does that's what you do instead of
job boards it'll help you do what you're
supposed to do yeah
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
rather
wash and guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
foreign
[Music]
Ty is my co-host Evan is in Indianapolis
hi Evan how are you
you better than I deserve what's up
um so I'm a young guy
last couple years
um
I'm a numbers cruncher and my numbers
aren't crunchy anymore I'm not able to
build my savings
and I'm not sure what to do with it
okay what do you make
uh I make 27.50 an hour okay and uh so
what is that about 70 a year
uh no it's more like 60 a year isn't it
yeah yeah okay what do you do
oh I'm an AG mechanic if I work on Farm
Equipment okay all right and
um how much debt do you have
uh about a hundred and seventeen
thousand on what
uh 75 on my house I've got 27 000 in
student loans
and 16 on a car
okay all right are you single
uh no getting ready to get married in a
month what she make
uh she's part-time because we had this
is where the whole two-year thing came
in uh we had a kid two years ago
um and she so she makes I think she
makes 15 an hour
and she works 20 to 25 hours a week
okay
all right well there's two sides of the
equation the income side and the out go
side
and if we want to change the numbers we
usually end up working on both
so you're working 40 hours she's working
15 somebody gonna be working more
if we want more money
or we're going to be working differently
meaning a new career if we want more
money and um and that the outgo side is
a car payment and a student loan payment
when you get rid of those by tearing
into them and making them the major
priority a priority above all other
things
and get rid of them uh then you know you
can get there but if you guys are making
a hundred thousand between the two of
you or 80 000 between the two of you you
can work through a sixteen thousand
dollar card debt and a twenty seven
thousand dollar student loan debt you
know in 18 24 months but you're gonna be
on beans and rice rice and beans you're
gonna be working overtime and you're
gonna sell so much stuff the dog thinks
it's next
are you budgeting
uh I mean I kind of do I mean I don't
have any no is the answer I don't have a
yeah no okay yeah and I'm not that's not
a setup question but when somebody says
I can't seem to get caught up I can't
seem to pile up savings we have baby
steps anyway so we want you a thousand
dollars baby step one that's for
emergencies then you're attacking this
debt but you've got to know where your
money is going and if you're not
budgeting you're gonna have a hard time
getting traction whether you're in baby
step one getting a thousand dollars baby
step two knocking that off baby step
three saving up three to six months
emergency fund if you're not budgeting
you have a greater chance of spinning
your wheels because you just simply
don't know where the money's going so so
when are you getting married
uh October the 7th awesome hey we're
gonna give you a wedding gift oh I'm
gonna put you and the bride through
Financial Peace University both of you
have to go if I give it to you for free
do you promise
yes I promise nine lessons it also
includes the world's best budgeting app
every dollar the premium version which
connects to your bank and I want you to
jump in that immediately and start using
it today I'm going to give it to you
right now Austin's gonna pick up and tie
you into it but get on the every dollar
app like Ken was saying because here's
what we find
research has shown across the general
population that when people start doing
a written budget each month they have a
10 to a 15 percent lift in their money
because there's that much in Lost and
just disorganization and impulse
spending we find it's actually more than
that because the people we're dealing
with are different than the general
public the people we're dealing with are
like you Evan they're sick and tired of
being sick and tired and they're about
ready to bust into something
and so they lean in even harder on that
budget and they make every one of those
dollars squeal
they make every one of those dollars
behave and that's why we even call the
budget every dollar every dollar has an
assignment and that's why the budgeting
app is called that every dollar has a
name every dollar has an assignment and
so you're just going to get
um
uh merciless on making the money that
the two of you have coming in behave and
squeeze every dime out of it increase
your income decrease your outgo and then
walk these baby steps and if Financial
Peace University will help you do that
and uh certainly the every dollar
budgeting app will help you do that so
check those out we're going to give them
to you free as a wedding gift and get
you started because I've been right
where you are Evan when people say can
Ken caught that beautifully because I
used to say that too I can't seem to get
and what that usually means is I haven't
been able to out earn my disorganization
I haven't been able to out earn my
stupidity I haven't been able to out
earn my impulse spending I haven't been
able to out earn my lack of a plan and
nobody can by the way and I used to
think I'd just go get more money because
I'm an abundant sky and I would go get
more money and then I would screw it up
you know and so you know you've got to
make the money that you have behave and
when you're managing that well you
become what's called a faithful Steward
someone who is stewarding their money in
a trustworthy Manner and God looks down
and goes oh wait there's one in
Indianapolis that gets it yeah huh who
knew you know and uh we might be able to
let him manage some more that's right if
he's managing what he has well help
hello that's a basic biblical principle
and last piece of encouragement Evan if
you budget first dive into every dollar
start to see where the money is you'll
be more motivated to do extra work
because as an AG mechanic who can work
on those big old machines that I don't
even know how they work right he can
work on a lot of different engines he's
got some transferable skills there's a
lot of side work where you as a mechanic
can make really good money but you're
more motivated to do that when you go
okay now I'm actually getting ahead
because I'm now disciplined and I have a
plan yeah and where do I want to be in
10 years right so now you're going okay
I'll go bust it yeah and whatever I want
to be in my career in 10 years yeah
that's a plan now this is how it works
boys and girls beautiful hey Austin will
pick up and get you signed up we'll get
you taken care of Susan's in New York
hey Susan welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
I have a question
um I'm currently in a condo that I want
to sell and I'm looking at either
renting it out and then buying something
new
um or maybe selling it and kind of
taking this like windfalls we want to
call it that that's going on in real
estate and pay off my debt and then also
buy something new either way I feel like
I want to leave this condo but I'm
afraid to let it go because I I'm not a
good interest rate on it and I'm like
it's called a windfall you you nailed it
oh You're Gonna Take the Money and Run
let it go let it go oh my God how about
that day if you didn't see that come no
you're right that was on key but I hope
I never see it coming again Jay did the
exact same thing yesterday but it was a
little better well Jade is that a lot
better than me
so anyway yeah Susan we've been
interrupted here by a solo that was
uninvited the deal is this
um we yeah you don't want to keep the
condo because you're becoming a landlord
by default
not by intent if you own another house
and you are debt free
and you had a problem you know and you
wouldn't go borrow on that house in
order to buy a condo in the city
you just wouldn't do it and effectively
by not selling this it's the same thing
as if you bought it
you know in terms of a balance sheet or
in terms of the decision-making Paradigm
and so yeah you're much better off to I
can't even say it yes you went there you
caught yourself yeah it's just uh okay I
gotta chill but yeah let it go yeah
that's what you need to do and
you're going to be humming that around
the house tonight and Sharon's gonna be
like what are you doing you're gonna
play Coleman who are you that's all you
do to say she'll understand Ken
Coleman's fault she'll understand so
many things are but hey you've taught
this for years the idea of being a uh
or even or even local yes increase
headaches yeah just you know yes real
estate's a good investment but very few
people back into it you need to walk
into it with cash after you got the rest
of your finances straightened out so
sell it Susan sell it please that's what
I would do if I woke up in your shoes
and thank you for the call this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality host of
the Ken Coleman show and author the
number one best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host as we
talk about your job your life your money
your where your money comes from your
work Ken is an expert in that area and
he can help so jump in the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Jim is with us in Vancouver hi
Jim welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for having me on sure
what's up um
I'm Colin from just outside Vancouver in
British Columbia here and basically I
was wondering if it was smarter for me
to buy a house or start start a business
first and if you would think buying a
house would be smarter how would I go
about that with today's like housing
market buying a house in terms of to
live in is your home or as a rental
property
it would be to live in as my own ideally
with a sweet torrento but that might be
further down the line okay are you
single
I'm single yeah what do you make
um I'm 20 and I still do live with my
parents but I currently make 35 bucks an
hour what's the business you want to
start
um it would be in the
equipment services and Welding industry
uh-huh
okay obviously you know how to do
equipment services and Welding where are
you going to get your customers
uh so I got quite a few connections from
past jobs at farms and whatnot from when
I was a bit younger
so I would be able to get a lot of
customers in the agricultural
um
type of work is that business
well what I'm getting at is he said
house or start business and so I'm
wondering is there a lot of capital
outlay like you're gonna have to put a
lot of money into this to launch this
business idea
again I haven't really put a whole lot
of thought
like I get I put a lot of thought
towards starting the business but I
haven't really tallied up the numbers
because
um I've just been told that for buying a
house if you're self-employed the bank
doesn't look super highly on that rather
than if you make a steady income out of
place that's been around for a long
longer they're going to want to say two
well in America they're going to want to
say two tax for two years of tax returns
I don't know what it is in British
Columbia but two years of tax returns as
a self-employed person proves you make
money other than that there's no problem
at all being self-employed but uh but
obviously you can't move in there with
uh and again I do not know the mortgage
process in uh British Columbia I can't
comment on that I'm ignorant about it so
but you'd have to find that out but I
think you're probably you know you're on
the right track there with that issue
how much money do you have saved
um so I currently have 35 000 in my
savings and then I got just under 30 000
invested
okay good for you all right
and um you you are in the welding and uh
equipment Services business now making
35 an hour
that's correct okay and so are do you
have the ability to do side jobs in the
same industry without uh stepping on
your current employers customers or
stealing from them in any way
that's that's the thing that I said
sorry in my email earlier your phone's
breaking up I didn't understand you try
again
um I do have the ability to work on side
jobs from home and also from the shop
without getting in the way of my current
career yeah without ethics problems with
your current employer right exactly okay
all right so what I would do is uh I
would not start my business full-time I
would start at part-time and and start
doing some side gigs and I would go get
me a rental Pro a place to rent and just
you know move out of your parents house
you're 20 years old
um and I would not buy a house right now
I would just keep piling up cash you got
plenty of time there's nothing to do
with the housing market it's got to do
with where you are and then I want you
to build up that side gig build up that
side gig to where you're making more
with it than you are during your day job
then you're ready to quit and run your
job run your business full time
the big deal here that you're going to
discover Jim and I want you to discover
this by actually doing it not not in
theory not discussing it what you're
going to discover is is that doing the
welding and being an excellent welder is
a different skill set than running a
business
yeah you can be an excellent technician
and still run the business poorly you
could be in you can run a business well
and be a horrible technician people do
that sometimes but uh what often happens
is someone is a great chef and so they
automatically assume they need a
restaurant
well it's a completely different thing
to run a restaurant than it is to be a
chef
the only thing that's in common is food
that's the only thing I mean Chef is one
skill operating a business is another
skill and that that's what I'm seeing
with you so I I think you're probably
very good at what you do you sound very
competent and confident and um so I
would want you to just build this up on
the side what do you think yeah the only
got to add to that is while you're doing
the work on the side see there's no risk
here you're not all in you got a great
job no conflict of interest and now I'm
learning the business with zero risk and
Dave's right there's a process of
welding and then there's I'm selling
these parts and that's a whole different
ball game then I'm running my business
and while I'm doing it on the side I'm
learning by experience but I'm also
going to sit with people who are winning
in the industry I will tell you this
Dave I think the most underrated
question in the history of the world is
will you help me and will you help me in
this case a young man who's 20 who
approaches a guy maybe in his 30s or 40s
or 50s or 60s and says hey I want to get
into this business one day can I buy
your lunch or coffee and will you just
tell me what I need to know and you
helping me is you just giving me some
knowledge and some wisdom and I have
found that successful people are very
willing to help that person who asked
that question and shows up with a
willingness to learn pad and paper notes
on your phone I don't care how you do it
and if you do that here's what happens
now you get all this wisdom and
knowledge from somebody who's been way
out in front of you and then you begin
to apply it on the side and Dave's right
that picks right back up where Dave's
advice is at some point you're going to
scale it to the point where you can walk
away from the day job right into working
for yourself but there's no risk here
and patience is the key it's hard to be
patient when you're 20. I mean crap it's
hard for me to be patient at 49 but it's
really hard to be patient when you're 20
but patience is what sets you up for the
Long Haul and I think that's the that's
the only thing I'd add to what you said
I thought the advice was fantastic so
don't buy a house no move out don't
start your business full-time start at
part-time build it up build it up build
it up build it up learn the business
skills and I'll send you a copy of our
number one best-selling book entree
leadership which is how we show people
what our Playbook has been on running a
business how we grew the Ramsey
Solutions business from a card table in
my living room to now almost 1100 folks
on the team and over 300 million a year
in revenue and we'll show you how we did
that and so but that's the skill set
it's a different set of skills than
welding and you got to be good at both
to make this work this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host thanks for being here America
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in and
we will talk Joe is in Lake Charles
Louisiana hi Joe welcome to the Ramsey
Show
yes sir thank you all for taking my call
sure what's up
so my question today is
um
a couple in our church is offering to
owner finance their house to us and I'm
just calling to see if that is going to
be a smart play with my current
situation
okay
um
well we took you know we can check your
current situation so how much debt do
you have
um right now we're on baby step two we
still have about 40 42 000
um which ranges from a credit card car
note what's your household income
um 65 to 70 000. so when do you plan to
do be done with the 42.
um where we're snowballing I mean by two
two and a half three years okay would be
yeah that sounds reasonable
um we tell folks Joe not to buy a home
while they're in debt
okay because
um
you know Murphy will move in your spare
bedroom and the water heater will break
the roof will leak and the heat and air
will go out and you're broke because
you're still in debt and then you got a
real mess on your hands so what appears
to be a blessing because of the timing
is not going to be a blessing it would
end up being a curse so I would tell you
to wait and that may mean that this
couple sells the house to someone else
and that's fine and you'll you know God
will have something else for you
there'll be another plan when you're
ready and you have a good emergency fund
and a good down payment and you have no
debt and you move into a house in that
situation the house can be a blessing
not a curse but when you move into a
house broke you just get broker that's
why they call them brokers
you know it's just it's a bad idea don't
do it don't do it James is that ready
yeah okay all right so uh they sent me
this thing God can this I don't know if
you saw this or not I haven't seen this
is a little bit it's not exciting oh
it's not okay it's scary so I mean we
get scam stuff all the time people using
my name oh you know people using you
know saying Dave Ramsey said do this
Dave Ramsey to do that and it's like
well of course Dave Ramsey doesn't say
to do that that's done he wouldn't do
that that's and you know anybody that
knows us know these things but then
people that don't know us they think I'm
endorsing you know bullcrap so this one
pops up this one's scary because it's AI
That's what I was going to ask you yeah
so you're gonna play it play it this is
on Instagram
this is the dumbest thing I've seen and
I don't know when total credit card debt
surged to 1.03 trillion dollars it marks
the highest level ever on record that
part's already fed dating back all the
way to 2003.
um I have about 16 000 worth of worth of
debt um it includes a car a card
okay so what you need to do and this
applies to my listeners at home is go
apply for an economic recovery package
today do you hear me the fastest way is
to settle it and pay pennies on the
dollar for what you owe and you can do
that using a free service through the
economic recovery program today thank
you sir wow hey we love you you hold on
a second Kelly's gonna pick up okay yeah
the economic recovery package and pay
pennies on the dollar and you of course
you swipe down and you go to this
website to buy their crap and uh and
obviously I mean I've said AI when I
first heard it on my computer it was AI
but when I heard it now just now in the
studio that doesn't it's not even AI
it's just a bad voice yeah he got one
not even a little phrase he got one
little phrase that was close but to
somebody who doesn't listen to you much
and did a drive-by on YouTube that's
nasty that is really bad it was an
Instagram thing so of course we got the
attorneys on it we'll get them shut down
Instagram shut them down but uh then
they pop back up as quick as you shut
them down because it's you know it's a
scam
yeah it's they're everywhere but yeah I
I they just you know
you don't notice but it changed from
these earbuds in our ears to the
microphone with the in front of our face
that's exactly and uh and then the thing
in front of your face it makes it look
like I'm saying it and uh and then
closes out with with me actually closing
the call out of course you know the
ultimate deception bookend it with
actual real stuff from you yeah it's
very you know that man all fraudulently
and in violation of copyright by the way
too but yeah wow wow so no we do not
endorse the economic Recovery Act which
doesn't even exist
yeah what a joke does not exist there's
no such thing economic okay and so and
you can settle your debts for pennies on
the dollar yeah you can do that but what
this is is one of these scam uh debt
consolidation places yes and uh they're
getting you into a debt consolidation
process and oh my but that part was
brilliant because that's the kind of
fooiness that we hear from DC they say
things like economic Recovery Act and we
all go oh they're here to help yeah
economic yeah yeah
you're right that that's that's
troubling though it's trouble Ronald
Reagan has a famous quote he said the
most scary words in the English language
are I'm from the government and I'm here
to help yeah that's exactly right amen
and amen the economic Recovery Act and
just just what does that even mean yeah
it's not even an act by the way oh it is
an act but it's not that kind of an act
wow wow crazy stuff you're gonna try to
rip your voice off practice a little
better than that come on man sound like
I was from California
not enough Tennessee in that there were
no toying in that Doug it's in Grand
Rapids hey Doug what's up
hey Dave and Ken how are you guys doing
today better than we deserve what's up
hey excellent I'm glad I'm speaking to
you guys I've been listening to the show
for about six years now and it's a
little bit embarrassing to state that uh
my wife and I are not completely out of
debt yet because we're what I like to
say and I hear you say on a show all the
time we're sort of ramsey-ish
um we did successfully pay off 88 000 of
student loans 2021. that's good um huge
weight lifted all the shoulders and with
all the student loans speak going on
right now it's amazing to not have to
deal with that
um but my question today has to do with
Roth IRAs because we still have 62 000
in debt um on three line items two of
them are cars and one is a camper
um how much do you owe on a camper
camper wheel 24 000. okay so one third
of this is a camper okay yep yeah and
the other 40 or 38 000 is broken into
how many what kind of car
how much we have a 27 on the Tahoe and
nine or almost ten thousand on an edge
okay all right so you have a car and a
camper problem okay
yeah
um now what's your household income
we bring in Gross about 160 a year so
we're only at about 41 percent of our
annual incomes we're a little bit below
the 50 that you teach okay and so and
you want to pull out your Roth
well the question is because I've
actually listened to show for six years
and I've never heard this question so I
may have a good one
um and I know you teach not to pull from
retirement because of the penalties and
taxes associated with doing that but in
our case we each my Wi-Fi and I each
have a Roth IRA in my name I have a Roth
of ten thousand dollars
um
and she's got five thousand in her name
and my question was about the cash
equivalents because obviously after
taxes absolutely not this is not a Roth
problem or a tax problem or a penalty
problem this is a Doug problem
mm-hmm duck real Behavior you make a 160
Grand and you owe money on a camper
yeah come on and you want to cash out
your freaking retirement
for a camper
no we also rent that out yeah
no Dave I'm in the camper investment
business no you're not
yeah you know better than that dude
what's it worth you have anything that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
gone yeah it's
appreciating either you pay these cars
and these campers off in the next 18
months out of your cash flow and you
guys quit being ish
or you know because here's the problem
you keep treating the symptom
and you know when you take this money
out of retirement and start with it's
not enough to do spit
there's not enough money in there but if
you did take it out you keep treating
the symptom and the symptom is the debt
the problem is the Doug
the Dougie okay so so you got a guy you
guys are gonna have to quit being ish
that's what we're saying you're going to
get on a decent plan get on it get on
every dollar you and your wife sit down
and go okay we knocked out 88 000. now
we look kind of foolish sitting here
with these debts making 160 Grand we
make too much money to be this freaking
broke you have no money in retirement
Doug
I mean you have five thousand dollars
that's pitiful it's pitiful and you make
a hundred and sixty thousand dollars a
year come on man
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions we have a thing called the
debt free stage we also have a viewing
area where you can come in get free
homemade chocolate chip cookies and
coffee come by and visit us if you're in
town from Boise Idaho or something like
that so we got a group of ladies sitting
here on the front row we just met him at
the break from Boise so hey people come
from All Over America and visit
Nashville and sometimes we're one of the
places they stop and see we do the show
on the glass from one to four every day
central time and if you come and watch
you'll agree that it's pretty much like
watching ugly paint dry but there you go
hey I don't resemble that hey hey watch
out what's happening hey but also we
have the debt free stage in that Lobby
and that's where Mike and Lindsay are
hey guys how are you hi I'm doing good
welcome where do you guys live St Louis
Missouri there we go awesome and how
much data have you paid off uh 360
000. yo how long did that take about 32
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
a 120 000 to 350 000. okay in three
years you double your over double your
income we did almost triple it yep wow
what do y'all do for a living uh I am an
internal medicine doctor ah there we go
and I work in the financial services
industry well that's fake enough good
okay all right excellent so now you're
yeah so that's a way to double or triple
your income the two of you excellent
very good so uh goodness what kind of
debt was the 360. uh mostly student
loans about 346
000 with student loans whatever it says
the doc yeah the rest was an investment
loan and a car loan okay wow very cool
how long you been on med school
uh about well out of medical school no I
mean out of residency about three years
about three years that's about this time
yep so you got out and you said let's
knock it out correct game on yep all
right so what how did you get connected
to this Ramsay stuff what made you all
do this yeah so
um we were probably Dave ish I had heard
about the Dave Ramsey Show before
Lindsay and I got married which was six
years ago and we were on our honeymoon
and uh being the financial guy I was uh
listening to the Dave Ramsey Show
podcast wow uh and then Lindsay uh being
like I think she was reading a book
and she said what are you doing what are
you listening to and it was uh the Dave
Ramsey show we listened to the podcast
um and that's how we got first connected
and then uh my family gifted us uh FPU
for Christmas as well okay and so then
when she comes out of med school no
question about what we're gonna do
correct we're gonna knock this out pop
done done done very good Lindsay I gotta
ask you is the doctor in your world did
you share the process the journey as you
were doing it and if you did uh what did
you find the reaction was and and I'm
just curious how many other people that
are in your shoes to the doctors that
are actually even thinking about getting
after it the way you all did
pretty openly about it
um and honestly most of the people are
not doing what we did a lot of the
people are doing Public service loan
forgiveness
um or they just kind of are on the you
know 10 20-year plan they'll eventually
pay it off you know they make enough
money
um they want like the big expensive
house or the fancy car and all that
stuff docitis correct did they look at
you treat you like incredulously like
what are you thinking no never that type
of situation just more so could tell
that they didn't necessarily agree with
it right like that would be nothing that
they would ever do yeah yeah
yeah look at you I'll completely free 32
months that's Rowdy wow that is very
cool what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is because you're
successful at it
um I would say my key is uh the budget
and then also we we always had like
really short-term goals but then also
having the longer term goals we were
always having goals that we wanted to
get done within like you know a month or
two and then also what's our goal five
to ten years from now like what do we
want life to look like so that's really
what kept me going yeah I I would say
like consistency so like we knew how
much money was going towards debt and we
set that goal from the beginning and
just kept on going
um and also um you guys have heard the
phrase or use the phrase dream dates
um that was that was huge for us like
keep us motivated to keep us going
um look to the Future uh and what Legacy
we want to leave behind yeah you gotta
have a vision absolutely for your life
correct and uh when you have a shared
dream then that's the living like no one
else so that later we get to live and
give like no one else and that you got
to have that later you know in sight in
high definition and be able to tell
what's really going on with it way to go
you guys way to go I'm curious I I don't
know if I don't know if I've ever asked
anybody this question but you're a
financial guy and you're in that world
and so you're probably academically
trained like I was uh the same way
because there's probably uh I don't know
two or three hundred podcasts and radio
shows on money out there oh why why what
was it that a financial guy goes well
this is okay I can listen to this yeah I
think for me it was
honestly before getting married to
Lindsay I didn't know debt or have debt
um and I knew it just threw you under
the bus I brought all the debtors
but I think the biggest thing is we uh
knew before marriage that we wanted to
tackle the debt and with covid and no
interest we wanted to get it out of our
lives for good I mean why this why why
were you listening to this show David's
because of your personality
over so his head can fit in here hold on
you and I
uh no I just really liked uh the
principles the baby steps uh now we're
on four five instances
clear path the clear path made sense
yeah okay that that I'll buy
way to go you guys we're very proud of
you congratulations and uh I'll show
you've had a baby yes all right and
brought they brought him with you right
we did he's four now no longer a baby
yeah that's right wow very cool very
cool so six years married four-year-old
and 32 months after med school boom this
is gone hey we got a copy of the uh baby
steps millionaires book for you in the
live and give box and the baby The Total
Money Makeover book and a Financial
Peace University membership probably got
all those already but you can give them
away and I find somebody who wants them
and so what's the four-year-old's name
Christopher all right Christopher here
we go man ready your mom and dad have
changed your life buddy you don't even
know how much yet you have a family tree
that has been changed but by two Heroes
right here 360
000 paid off in 32 tombs making one
Lindsay and Christopher from St Louis
counted down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one yeah
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done you gotta love it
so Ken there is an antidote to the
student loan crisis and uh we just
observed it yeah because human beings
taking responsibility because the
private student loan forgiveness as she
said some of these docs are counting on
has a
1.6 percent success rate
98.4 percent of the people that apply
for that do not get it
let's say all of them
so these docs are screwed up by betting
the their their Futures on the private
student loan forgiveness public student
loan forgiveness act it's it doesn't
work it's another time your government
has lied to you
and so we're gonna be having this coming
Tuesday night Jade wash all Rachel Cruz
me are going to be doing a free live
stream for a couple hundred thousand of
you that are going to be viewing it's at
7 pm Central Time this coming Tuesday
night so student loan debt in America
how we got here and how we're going to
get out yeah we're going to show you
some real solutions this is Ramsey
Solutions that's what we're here for and
we're not here for something that's
going to if you're looking for easy I I
don't I can't help you with easy if
you're looking for microwave and quick I
can't help you with that we sell crock
pots baby
32 months
they've been scratching and clawing
those folk 32 months they went through
Financial Peace University they listened
to the podcast they've read the books 32
months of nothing another free 360
000 in debt
yeah go to ramseysolutions.com student
loans and sign up for Tuesday night this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Joe's with us in Houston Texas hi
Joe how are you
pretty good uh so my question today Dave
and uh Ken is uh I worked for an
automation supplier company for the oil
and gas industry I've been here for
almost a year my responsibilities have
increased uh a lot more than I thought
they would and I would like to bring up
uh
getting a raise to uh to my leadership
and stuff like that and kind of wanted
to know about how to go about doing that
how much have you got a number in your
mind a percentage that you've done some
research on or is this just a hunch and
a Feeling
uh so so I'm definitely making less than
what I was previously with the job I
left in you know uh where we were
maintenancing the solutions that were uh
being sold by by different companies
and now I'm designing and implementing
those uh so I took a pay cut to come to
this job for more freedoms more
responsibilities and chances to grow
and the number I've got is about 12 to
15 is what you want as a raise
yes and you've been there a year have
you had an annual review or is that
process in place
uh so I had a six-month review and
everything was everything with that was
was gold stars and from what I was told
so when did The increased
responsibilities get put on you give me
a timeline
at the six month Mark and and you were
told this of like hey here's what we're
doing you're doing a great job gold
stars now we're going to add this this
this and this is that how it went
yes did you bring up okay hey I'm glad
for the review uh is there an increase
in cop what's that look like how am I
measured did you bring that up at the
time
so I brought that up at the time and the
company I work for is growing
and uh so they were like okay we're
gonna push off your raise until so then
I asked for a six percent
they said we're going to push it off
till October well then the
responsibilities that was It was
supposed to increase it's gone beyond
that in this in the six months
because we're we're developing a new a
new department for for our branch and
I've been kind of given that okay and
that's now
I make 82.5 okay and so you're asking
for like 10 grand
yeah okay
all right
and they're supposed to review it in
October anyway so just a few weeks yes
yes sir okay all right
all right I'd Hold the Line I'd hold the
line on the number if and again Dave I
want you in the yeah it's all The
Narrative of how you couch it okay so
just the the best way to do well but a
lot of these things especially in
business is just trade shoes for a
minute okay if you're the leader you're
the owner you're the manager that's
making these decisions okay how would
you want to be
uh addressed how would you want this
conversation to sound and I'm an owner
of a company I'll tell you how I want it
to sound
um I'm happy to talk to anybody about
their comp I'm happy for them to talk to
leadership here anytime about their comp
uh and and you know here's the thing
you're not entitled to anything
you earn it and you have said you're
earning it but I mean I had one guy come
in my office Joe a few years ago and
he's like well I've got this degree in
that degree the poor guy had more
degrees than a thermometer and he he
said you know people that have degrees
like me at other places you know they
make uh fifty thousand dollars more a
year than I'm paying and I said yeah
then you're you're paying me I said I
understand that but we don't pay for
degrees here this is a small business
honey your raise is effective when you
are
okay and so that's what the owner is
looking for your raise is effective when
you are you've made the case to me
listening to you that you've been
effective and you've gotten the
increased responsibility and you're
stepping up and you're taking emotional
ownership of these areas and so you're a
valuable team member is what it sounds
like to me and so but the way you want
to couch it if you're on the other side
of the desk is how Joe I mean think
about it you want to say uh not I
deserve more money simply go I think I'm
adding a lot of value do you think I'm
adding a lot of value if I'm adding
value I need to ask you how do I go
about talking to you guys in a proper
way without sounding ungrateful because
I'm very grateful I love this place I
love the opportunity I love the growth I
love the added responsibility
um and I you know what's the right way
if you're me to ask you guys about
compensation and I I I'd really like to
make more and what do I need to do is
there anything I'm not doing that I'm
that I'm do you know is there anything I
I can add or is there do I need to do
something different to qualify for some
increased compensation and if somebody
says to me how can I what can I do to
make myself more valuable so you want to
give me more money
that's an easy that's an easy thing for
me as an owner I can do that one okay I
can go okay because in you know like I
had a guy one time he's working on a
deal and he brought in an extra million
dollars
that really happened that blew my mind
he just he added this thing to a deal he
was doing negotiating a deal for us and
he added this thing and so in his
commission structure did not pay him on
that million dollars but you know what
we paid him anyway you know why because
I want him to do that again
okay because he added value you see what
I'm talking about so a lot of value in
that case that's a big number but the
the thing is here I I think you say I am
I I think I'm adding value am I adding
value and if I'm not adding enough what
do I need to be doing to qualify for
increased compensation because I really
want to be one of your best team members
and I also want to make some good money
and tell me how to do that man yeah I
agree with that however I would also add
to this Joe they promised you a six
percent I I would ignore that because I
think he's due I think he's doing a lot
more than six six a joke in this yeah
maybe he needs he needs anything he's
got to have some Marketplace research on
that like if somebody comes to us and
says yeah but he's he's on a startup and
they're they're adding stuff they're
adding new products they're adding new
projects and things to his plate left
and right left and right and he's making
80 already he's he's worth another 10. I
think he is but he's got to make that
case and I'm just pointing out that he's
going in asking for 12 to 15. they've
asked six he needs to show market right
he wouldn't ask for 12 15. I would oh
open-ended question okay because he was
saying he has talked about six back in
the summer I feel like I'm doing all
these things what have I got to do yeah
I always say that too and you know that
kind of thing and and then if they come
back at six you go okay I need to know
what I got to do to get double that um
because I kind of thought I was in that
zone and apparently I'm not so they've
added responsibilities so you know if
you talk to me that way and you don't
you don't start trying to but let me as
soon as somebody starts playing Hardball
with us at Ramsay on uh Ray's
negotiation right we just go you know
it's probably not gonna work out here
right because we're not going you know
you're gonna negotiate come on I mean
ask how you can help yeah and if you
kill it and drag it in here we'll share
it with you baby yeah I mean it's not
we're not greedy but but you know just I
show up every day and breathe and so I
get money that's not what Joe's doing
right but if you if you're out there and
you think well I just show up every day
and I'm you know I actually took a
shower daily and I expect a raise I mean
come on man there's no just shower daily
race that's there's not one of those so
um you know it's crazy what's out there
and the way people think about this
stuff so you know here's the thing if
you want to be an extremely valuable
team member always be asking what you
how you can add value you how I can lift
the place not what I can take from it
so if we're interviewing someone and the
first two sentences all they want to
know is what they get
then we're done with the interview
because they're there to take they're
not there to add
they're going to work a j-o-b work as
little as possible come in late leave
early and steal while they're there
and so you want to present that the
exact opposite of that scenario agree
when you're interviewing or when you're
negotiating so to speak for a raise but
it's not negotiating no it's asking
leading questions yes and also being
informed on what you're asking the other
day in in one of our technology roles a
very unusual Mitch role but he said I
gotta I got a recruiter coming at me
offering me X more and he goes I don't
want to leave it's crazy amount of money
he goes what should I do and and that's
the way to approach it not like I love
that if you don't match this guy I'm out
of here right because we'd be going see
you wouldn't want to be you you know
that's right and um but but if he comes
in and goes that you know what we were
not able to match it but he wanted to
stay we were able to respond to his
situation and make him feel good about
staying by giving him a great raise and
it was it was an unscheduled raise hello
so that's okay all that's fine but this
is a how your the attitude you approach
it are you a giver or are you a taker
are you a parasite
or are you someone that's adding to the
whole process and if you're adding to
the process and the people don't respect
that with your in your wallet you
probably need to look for another place
Joe I think you got a good situation and
you're a good guy this is going to work
out for you this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
America Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book paycheck to purpose is my co-host
he hosts also the Ken Coleman Show on
Sirius XM as a podcast here on the
Ramsey networks and uh very popular
answering your questions about jobs and
work and career and you can find him
every day doing that and of course be
sure and check in with us here today
he'll help you too the phone number
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Alex is in Cleveland Ohio hi Alex
how are you
I'm great thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
I'm trying to prioritize my money
between my mortgage saving for
retirement and replacing my car after
all my budget expenses are covered so if
I put everything extra towards the house
I could pay it off in six years which
sounds great but my parents prioritize
paying off their house before retirement
so now they don't really have retirement
okay how old are you
I'm 33. okay so if you did that
you'd be 39 years old
exactly so mathematically you would not
be your parents
because you definitely could save a lot
for retirement if you had no house
payment between now and retirement
between 39 and 65 right
that's a good point okay yeah show your
parents your parents the fear that came
from your parents situation is not valid
in your case however I'm still not going
to tell you to do that but I just think
it's good to work out the math for a
second now
um
so you're out of debt everything but the
house right
correct and you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses set
aside correct
right I have 15 000. good okay then
you're at what we call baby step four
baby step four is say 15 of your income
no more
into retirement if you have no payments
but a house payment 15 of your income
going into retirement should leave you
some money in your budget
what's your household income
77 000 pre-tax post-tax it ends up being
about 57.
how much is your house payment
is let's see I wrote that down where did
I go
um
1330.
okay how are you paying off your house
in six years if you save nothing I don't
hear that in these numbers
I've had an extra 1 300 each month
Oh I thought you said you had an extra
500 each month
that would be if I put into retirement
oh I see so if you put 800 into
retirement you'd have 500 to go towards
the car okay and so what's your current
car worth
roughly 6
. what do you want to spend on the next
car
I'm gonna need
to speak in if I buy used which is the
plan okay so if you buy 15 and your
current one's worth six you need nine
right and that takes uh well it says it
takes
not even a year well it takes you know
it takes a little over it takes about 14
15 months to save that up at 500 a month
right
exactly okay so 14 or 15 months you got
your car upgrade meanwhile you're
putting 15 of your income in and then
we'll start paying extra on the house
I'd only have 500 extra to go towards
the hospital if I would no but you know
you've also you've extrapolated out into
the distant future no raises
that's true too yeah so it's a myth so
the reality is you're going to pay off
the house probably in six or seven years
while putting 15 away while replacing
this car with a decent thing everything
you've described to me is very sane
you are not a cray-cray American you're
not out of control thank you I mean
really you you're very level-headed I
mean you I I was a bit afraid you were
going to say 35 000 car and I was going
to have a small cow right here on the
radio okay
Mom raised Mom and Dad raises yeah I'm
telling you so you you really have your
your
your your feet on the ground in a
beautiful way you got a lot of common
sense kiddo so you're gonna be fine yeah
so the thing is this you're going to
accomplish everything the the way we ran
out the case studies and the way we've
talked to literally is millions of
people that we've made into millionaires
is that this idea if you're putting 15
away don't put more than that but don't
put less than that you're going to end
up a multi-millionaire with that alone
and you're going to get the house paid
off on average and your numbers are not
different than that uh you know under 10
years it might be seven it might be 6.5
and it depends on the curve on your
raise as well how quick you how much
your raise goes up and I'm curious what
do you do for a living yeah I want to
know this
yeah I work in marketing for a small
company I'm just wondering Alex if you
aren't thinking about the gig economy
freelance marketing after hours to speed
up this buy a new car fund I would
really be considering that if you have
the margin in your life with your skill
set in today's Marketplace uh freelance
work as a marketer that's what I would
be doing to get the car paid for what
kind of marketing are you doing for this
small company
design Flyers
show content what I love doing is like
talking with engineers and then getting
them to speak in English instead of geek
that's a full-time job uh it's also
extremely valuable you're a translator
in a digital economy
um the uh
so let me
sometimes and you tell me if I'm wrong
but sometimes when someone says I'm a
marketer at a small company
the small company part of the phrase is
code for I feel like I'm not being paid
what I could make somewhere else
yeah they're very fair but no that
wasn't what I asked
did you say that accidentally in that
statement
yeah
like you make 70 but you think if you
moved over Yonder you might make 90
. yeah yeah I'd be thinking about that
yeah
yeah and freelancer I can't say that
enough yeah and and lots of freelance
stuff on the side because if you can do
digital translation from the digital
humans to the non-digital humans you
have a skill
well you gotta look at five
five yeah
no not International you just start
looking in your area uh you're just
getting on the Internet you're talking
to people there's a lot of freelance
work there's a couple sites I don't want
to endorse them because I haven't done a
ton of research on other companies like
your company
that cannot afford a full-time marketer
yeah uh would buy it would pay for some
side gig uh contractor work it's the
same exact same work done in that
situation
um because we have a lot of folks inside
of our building that do what you do
they're they're digital translators I
never called them that before today but
they that's what they do and so you get
on a squad with the digital teams and
then you have to learn to speak their
language and then we also have to learn
that the consumer you know what's the
consumer facing after we write this code
what's it look like how's it sound how
does it feel and that kind of stuff so
yeah that's exactly what you're doing
and that's I'm telling you that's a very
valuable skill in the marketplace right
now I think you're worth more than
you're getting paid probably you need to
think about that you're an amazing it's
fun to talk to you you're amazing very
well done very well done you're going to
be very wealthy you don't have to worry
if you keep keep using the brain the way
you're using your brain right now you're
gonna be very wealthy your decision
making skills your thought Paradigm is
excellent this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we're so glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey guys um
we can use your help
if you want to help us out it doesn't
cost you a thing if you will click
subscribe or follow or whatever it is on
your podcast or your YouTube or whatever
and just let you know just sign up it
changes the algorithm moves the show up
in the rankings and causes other people
to know we're here it's a free way you
can say thank you to us
and uh so click follow click that and
use the share button and if there's not
a share button to share tell people tell
people or take clip click a link out and
go okay hey I saw this you guys got to
start watching the show you got you
won't believe it you got to start
listening to the show you won't believe
it and uh because it's absolutely
phenomenal how many of you are there
thank you uh the number of minutes being
downloaded is just astronomical uh on
the different uh versions it's
absolutely crazy and we appreciate you
thank you very much leave the five star
review you know all those kinds of
things really help change the algorithm
of whether these different Services push
the show to the front and make it as a
suggestion or not so thank you Austin is
in Milwaukee hi Austin welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call it's a
pleasure speaking with you sure what's
up
uh so I'll try to make it quick here but
I have a two-part question that kind of
revolves around my career that I was
hoping to get some answers or maybe
suggestions on what I could do as I've
been listening to you for quite some
time now and ever since I've been trying
to do everything right
um but I seem to back myself in a corner
here with uh work and any further work
uh to Major my income growth
um and I'm so I'm 23 years old and I'm
truck driving for a career I'm a
regional over the road uh trucker so not
uh Coast to Coast or anything I make
about 62k base gross pay
but after all my overtime I'll gross
roughly around 85k a year which is uh 5K
a month after taxes and uh Roth's 401K
contributions I have no debt although
I'm looking to make more money only
because I feel like I'm meant to do more
and I love my career and company I work
for so switching companies isn't
something I'm really looking to do even
though certain companies out there I
could get starting at 105k a year by
trading more of my time for money and
staying on the road longer which I know
is a big battle between making money and
taking your time the only problem with
being a trucker though is that I'm
restricted on how much I can work with a
side gig if I would or more suicide job
as legally you're only allowed to work
14 hours a day in a Max of 70 hours a
week but between each 70 hour work week
you need to be resting for 34 hours with
no pay even if it's a non-driving job
and so the only solution I would have to
think about getting is a
under the rug pay uh cash pay job and or
do I just accept a fate and make an
extra 20K by switching companies okay
while looking to try to make more yeah
so what's more important to you is it is
it staying in the the driving position
you really love it and then having this
time that you have now or is making more
money
what's more important because you gave
us the whole scenario but it comes down
to what is the biggest priority for you
yeah I mean I you know it it's it's
funny because I do enjoy my free time
but there's most weekends that uh I'm
either not doing something and I'm just
sitting there kind of uh not having
anything to do and then I feel like I
could be doing more well you can't so
here's what I don't understand so
forgive my ignorance is this the
regulation of the company saying hey
it's Federal regulator it's a Federal
Regulation you're not allowed to drive
so hiki so you can't yeah but he can't
did I understand that you can't work you
can't do anything any outside work and
receive uh income because if it's
reported it's outside the Federal
Regulation is that what I'm
understanding
I could during the week but I'm not home
during the week or except for one hour I
got that part I'm going that direction
okay so legally we can do something it's
just during the week so what is how many
hours do you have on a regular week
where you're not behind the oil of a car
uh typically it's about well you got 48
during the weekends because we get off
weekends and then it's typically
uh about
12 to 20 throughout the week all right
so 12 to 20 hours is what you can work
with to do something else because you
said I feel like I'm supposed to do more
so we have to first look at what
inventory of time you have to do other
work now we've got 12 to 20 hours so now
you start getting into well what is it
that I would do if I wasn't in the truck
what would this different type of work
be I believe you've got those ideas I
don't think I like you calls and doesn't
have an idea to so what would you do if
you weren't limited to the truck this
other idea of work doing something more
what is it
well I've I guess I've always uh had uh
had a not again I don't know if you call
it a dream but I've always uh wanted to
start my own business is I've had a
really good idea with it could spend
what's the best um uh it would be do I
make a business uh with protein bars um
because I actually am a bodybuilder and
that's one struggle I found with a nut
allergy is there is not a single protein
bar on the market that doesn't contain
nuts or at least manufactured in the
same position so let's make this big
dream let's bring it way down for a
second let's play with this 12 to 20
hours that's just if you were actually
working for somebody but you've got a
whole lot more time
to be able to to look into what would it
look like to put together a prototype
bar that doesn't have the nuts in it or
whatever it is that you've got figured
out you can figure out who's making
these things how many different
companies Across the Nation are putting
together protein bars just like a
manufacturer in any other business and
now I start to research and I figured
out and I figure out what it's going to
cost me who would make it can I just
sample it you've got all this time even
behind the wheel of a truck to be
listening to maybe podcasts about how to
come up with a strategy to launch
something like this there are people
that do this kind of stuff it's free so
you become an expert in what it would
take to launch a protein bar that's it
we start there because if this is the
dream
then we're not going to just launch into
the protein bar business there's a whole
lot of work so you're using all this
time to become an expert in what needs
to happen then we look at the finance
piece what's that going to cost
and so now you've got a plan here's what
I would have to do here's how much it's
going to cost and so now you begin to
save that money and you go slow you
don't risk a lot of money you try it you
test it this is a process so I would be
putting that desire to play in very
practical ways as I just described and
then over time you might see yourself
going all right I got to take a
different trucking job to make more
money to come up with an extra 20 000 to
put into my first protein bar and I've
already got several local stores that
are willing to carry it I don't have a
ton of inventory which means I don't
have a ton of risk and I'm beginning to
put it out there and I see does this bar
go somewhere maybe you look into it
enough where you go you know what I'm
going to transition from the truck to
actually working for a protein
supplement company because I can do that
I can work for them is this
entrepreneurial or is it an actual
professional path all of that will
become clear if you take your time and
use all that extra hours and energy to
dive into what is it going to take to do
this thing and that's that's how I do it
yeah you're the way you're describing
your situation is that uh there's only
two options doing what you're doing or
not doing what you're doing and
um because you're looking at it as an
All or Nothing instead of an incremental
by degree change and so what I just pan
back and say okay I'm 23 when I'm 33
what do I want to be doing
water then then what must be true that's
not true today for me to be able to do
that and then you start making okay
there's 32 steps to get there over the
next 10 years over the next 10 years
we'll start taking those 32 steps that's
what Kim was describing the first steps
of the 32 steps but you just Begin by
degrees moving in the right direction a
little bit at a time and that method of
thinking will cause you to be able to
move forward versus I I'm stuck you're
not stuck you can do the little steps in
the right direction right now that's
what Ken's describing for you this is
the Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thanks for joining us in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Joe and Emily are with us hey guys
how are you doing great doing good good
where do you guys live
uh just outside Madison Wisconsin in a
town called Baraboo wow very cool
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off
thousand dollars way to go and how long
did this take 14 and a half months good
for you and your range of income during
that time we started out at about 170
and we finished up at about 200.
excellent cool what do y'all do for a
living
I am the guy that everybody curses when
they try to get into those plastic
packaging
a plastic packaging guy I'm the plastic
packaging guy I'm that guy oh okay are
you talking like when you get like a box
in the mail and you can't even get it
open with an X-Acto Knife yep that's
right level that's him I really do curse
you
good
I love it what do you do Emily I am a
Quality Systems engineer all right very
cool well you guys are doing well
congratulations what kind of debt was a
72 thousand
it was a mix between credit cards we had
an ATV
um a HELOC loan that we did use for some
uh Home Improvements and uh a school
pledge for our church and finally a land
loan so during the height of covid we
went and purchased about 11 acres of
course you did yeah I mean we've been
looking for land for quite a while and
we just couldn't find anything that we
really really liked and then this one
just happened to pop up it's like nope
this is it we just knew it in our bones
this was it so what happened 14 and a
half months ago that changed everything
because you guys were in kind of normal
you're just buying stuff on credit right
and then you looked up and went this
sucks we're not doing this what happened
well actually the story goes back a
little further
um today is actually our sixth wedding
anniversary oh congratulations and uh
prior to us getting married I was a
single mom living paycheck to paycheck
and had over seventy thousand dollars in
student loans
[Music]
um when Joe and I got married
um he basically took a look at me and
said
uh can we do the best we possibly can to
live on one income essentially and
um basically everything that I was
bringing in throw it at those student
loans
and uh we got married
um long story short struggled a lot with
contentment during that time
realizing that you know we were we did
have a good income but trying to live on
that one paycheck
and
um
I switched jobs in 2021
um and
the great resignation kind of turned
into I don't know I was kind of looking
at the great regret yeah and
um just trying to get through each day
at work I was listening to music uh
streaming music to get through my day
and one day I just happened to think you
know I'll turn a podcast on instead
um and I
I call it that God thing that must have
happened I just happened to turn on the
Ramsey Show which I wasn't very familiar
with
and I it's my best promotional item by
the way
it just so happened that I was listening
to an episode one day and it was Ken
Coleman and Dave Ramsey and
um
you were talking about uh that very
thing that I was living with about
changing jobs and feeling like basically
you had wrecked your career by making
that change and I was really really in a
dark place at that time really really
hurting and
um listening to what the two of you were
saying about
um you know basically being a slave to
the lender and as soon as you get your
debts paid off you can go do and explore
what you're really passionate about and
um I didn't know what the baby steps
were at that point but I heard something
about an FPU class and I I knew I needed
to get that career assessment first of
all because I I didn't know what I I
didn't know about if I was doing the
right thing or the wrong thing at that
point I just I just needed needed some
guidance and so I wanted that career
assessment I I needed to uh get out of
debt so you go home and tell Joe all
this and Joe's like okay awesome this is
what I've been saying yeah this is what
I've been saying she had a great picture
but now what happened was what happened
was Emily you got a reason
to do it all of a sudden the reason was
escaping the crappy job in the toxic
environment right so I got to get this
cleaned up so I don't have to come into
work I don't have to do this yeah it
changes everything very cool yeah it's a
great why you gotta have a big old wine
if you're gonna do stuff you have to
have a reason to do it so all right
let's fast forward yeah so you're on
board right yeah and so you guys go
let's get after this when you got into
it was there a Moment In the Journey
where you hit that big momentum where
you really you both saw the Finish Line
we can do this
I think so I mean even when we first
started it was like wow the money we got
money that we didn't know we had
you know I'm not a budget guy I'm not a
guy that goes out just spends just to
spend but I'm not no no I don't I really
don't but I like I like you know tools
and stuff like that and if it's
something I can use around the house I
have no problem going I'm buying it but
so I wasn't crazy with it but going down
and doing the budget and sitting down
every month in June it was fast there's
no money here yeah it was like pulling
teeth to get me to do it yeah but once I
started seeing the money yeah showing up
out of nowhere it's like wow where did
all this so the budget reveals them
their nails yeah and there's the
momentum because you now have we can
actually nail this yeah that's great
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
that's not an oncoming train yeah then
it became fun because it was wow we're
watching these numbers just click off
yes I guess it's like here we go here we
go here we go what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt-ish
I've been telling people look into your
resources
um
as as far as side hustles we had our
little side hustles that we did but we
also found other resources
um we have friends that have a hobby
farm and we were able to assist them on
that farm and
it cut our grocery budget significantly
because we were able to get the fresh
fruits fresh vegetables from the farm
smart and
um what Joe was really good at canning
and preserving
Mr package Pro here yeah
I love it I love it way to go you guys
how does it feel it's amazing to be free
for the first time in six years and
really more than that
it's it's amazing
um we had a family medical emergency
just a couple uh months ago with a
family member and to be able to step
back and say you know what we can do
what we need to at this moment and not
have to worry about
um the money side of it was was such a
relief that's a big deal it's a big deal
way to go you guys we're proud of you
Heroes you're amazing man I just they're
kind of a little bit like floating
they're not quite touching the ground
pretty good that's pretty neat it's
pretty cool very cool and you brought
your daughter with you right what's her
name and age uh Reagan she's 13. all
right way to go all right so Reagan's
whole life has been changed too this is
pretty amazing hey we've got the I live
and give box for you it's a baby steps
Millionaire's book The Total Money
Makeover book and the Financial Peace
University membership Give It Away use
it however you want to do it it's our
way of saying thank you and our way of
saying congratulations well done very
well done Joe Emily and Reagan Madison
Wisconsin Area 72
000 paid off in 14 and a half months
making 170 to 200. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
three yeah
yeah this is how it's done I love it man
what cool people
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
s
thank you
[Music]
our scripture of the day Philippians 3
13-14 one thing I do forgetting what is
behind and straining toward what is
ahead I press on toward the goal to win
the prize for which God has called me
heavenward in Christ Jesus
Benjamin Franklin said the Constitution
only gives people the right to pursue
happiness
you have to catch it yourself
boy is that relevant today man that's a
mouthful
that's a mic drop I gotta love it Mike
dropped by old Ben Jeremy's With Us
Jeremy is in Tucson Arizona hi Jeremy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
uh so quick question my son youngest son
got himself stuck into a whole life
policy
and of course I want to talk him out of
it and get him to invest in something
else
so I know the biggest Hook is he can
borrow against his policy
I know that with the 401K you'll get
penalized
which leads me to maybe mutual funds
which I don't know a whole lot about
so I was wondering what's the major
difference between the 401K and the
mutual fund that he may be able to
borrow against in the future
okay
um how old is your son
is 23. okay
[Music]
um
well I I don't think
I mean number one let's just let's just
ask the question why is he going to
listen to you
well
really good
relationship with him and the whole
reason
because I kept pushing for uh to invest
to save money to think about his future
than him but then he picked a bad way of
doing it right and when you say son this
is a dumb way of doing it it's not a
good investment program what does he say
oh I can borrow against it that's his
big hook yes okay well no one ever got
rich borrowing their Investments
right they invest them and they forget
them completely against it yeah you're
borrowing against it is not is not a
method of wealth building
that's a method of selling Insurance
crappy insurance
but it's not a method of wealth building
right and that's what got him in he was
actually looking for help
and disability and death insurance is
what is where he started looking and
then they hooked him on the whole life
policy yeah
so I mean my point is is that we can
answer your question a 401k is not an
investment it is how an investment is
treated for taxes typically inside of a
401k you're going to find mutual funds
so you have a mutual fund that's either
covered with a coat keeping it warm from
taxes and the coat is called a 401k or
an IRA or a Roth IRA or it has no coat
and it's out in the cold and has taxed
but in both cases it's still a mutual
fund could be the exact same mutual fund
and um but wealthy people don't build
their investments in order to borrow
against them
yeah and so if he wants to become
wealthy he's picked a really bad way of
doing it number one borrowing against it
number two he's picked the probably one
of the worst Financial products alive
today
and it is the whole life policy because
it has a horrible rate of return in the
first three years that you pay 20x 20
times more for the same amount of life
insurance so you buy a hundred thousand
dollar whole life policy you buy a
hundred thousand dollar Term Policy if
the hundred thousand dollar whole life
if policy is a hundred dollars a month
the hundred the hundred thousand dollar
Term Policy is five dollars a month
that's what research tells us so it's 20
times more expensive ninety five dollars
extra per hundred
okay now where does that go it goes into
an investment called cash value and so
you and the cash value has no build up
for the first two to three years they
keep one hundred percent of your
investment as commissions the first
three years you have zeros on your cash
value build up the first three years
well that sucks and once you get past
having a really front loaded horrible
commission off the front end it finally
starts making money the average whole
life policy according to research
averages 1.2 percent rate of return not
gonna get rich on that either oh and
then when you finally get past all of
that if you actually build it up you can
borrow and pay them interest to use your
money
so if you have a savings account and you
want to borrow and you want to take
money out of your savings account you
don't have to pay money you just take
money out of your savings account but
with a whole life policy you want to
take money out you have to pay them
interest to use your money that you paid
20 times more to build up this thing
sucks
policy twenty thousand dollars worth of
cash value and then you screw around and
die which we all do
oh guess what happens to your 20 000
that you paid ninety five dollars extra
per month to build up after getting past
horrible rates of return and and no
command no build up at all for the first
three years because they kept it all as
a commission once you finally get 20 000
in there and you die they pay a hundred
thousand dollars
they keep your savings account so if you
had a savings account at the bank and or
if I start pitching you a savings
account on Tick Tock and I said hey
here's your savings account the first
three years you put money in
nothing happens we keep it all after
that it makes 1.2 percent and when you
die you lose your money
no one would put money in that
that's a whole life policy so nobody
ought to put money in a whole life
policy so you can just play this rant
back for your son Jeremy when it comes
out on the podcast and it'll answer his
question perfect that's exactly what I
would do and I'm not even I mean that's
exactly Sun watch this yeah this is just
don't do it don't do it son of Jeremy
you have been screwed by the life
insurance industry and they are very
good at their business of screwing
people it's unbelievable horrible
product let me tell you if you're poor
the way they get you
is the pawn shops the way they get you
is the rent to own the way they get you
is the payday lender
the way they get you is lottery tickets
if you're middle class the way they get
you is they make you believe you're
going to get rich on airline miles using
your stupid credit card well that's a
dumb butt idea
the way they get you is they get you
into a whole life policy that's a dumb
butt idea the way they get you is they
go sophisticated rich people lease their
cars no they don't
no they don't it's a dumb butt middle
class thing to do
so the whole life policy is the is the
payday lender of the middle class
it's a signal that you intend to be in
the middle class to stay there the rest
of your life because you got screwed by
the insurance companies
and I got to tell you man if you don't
like that and you sell whole life you
need to actually learn how your product
works and then if you have integrity
you'll quit selling that crap
because there's only two types of people
that sell whole life the ones that don't
understand it and the ones that are
Crooks because if you understand that
crap and you sell it you by definition
are a crook
because anybody that would sell someone
an investment that the insurance company
keeps their money that they put in there
upon death and call that a good deal is
a crook
that's just bull okay it's just absolute
scam stuff it just pisses me off and
I'll tell you what the whole life I
thought it had just about gone away and
freaking Tick Tock has revived whole
life
Tick Tock of all things
I mean people listen people if your
social media sounds like a Tic Tac you
sh you know there's only one thing you
should listen to on Tick Tock and that's
stuff we put out but other than that
it's awful it's a Barren landscape of
morons that's great it's crazy
absolute nuts oh God and the whole life
stuff is all over it like they just
invented it yesterday yeah it's the
oldest Financial product ma'am the
financial planning commit Community
completely abandoned this garbage 35
years ago no one sells whole life life
insurance except life insurance agents
no one in the financial planning
Community believes in it we've all been
looking at it going you've got to be
kidding for decades
and now as stuff comes back on Tic Tac
it's unbelievable well I got a new idea
out of this rant a new sponsor blood
pressure medicine for Dave when he goes
off on whole life this is fantastic you
can't stand those people it's
unbelievable I think you made that
abundantly clear that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the book so we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Rams and
baby steps go to ramsesolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramsesolutions.com and
click get started
[Music]